Hey ladies it's Joanna here so today's
workout it's all about working on your
arms and getting rid of the finger wings
yep we know that this is one of the most
common problematic areas and we cannot
spot reduced fat so this workout will
combine a 45-second of strength training
to tone up on the arms and also 45
seconds of active reps which will
combine some of my favorite kickboxing
moves you will not need anyways so
getting body warmed up give me your best
effort and let's do this together
so there will be a lot of push-ups
combining with a lot of punches so I
want you to give me strong punches
throughout the workout okay so the first
workout will be a wide to narrow foo
shaft so let's start on the mat okay
get on your knees I want you to start on
the white shoe shop and then into a
narrow switch a potential out white and
in narrow okay so the white shoe shop
will be working on a technical narrow
will be perfectly in the triceps and
your arms it is very difficult what you
can do it's a bigger step in narrow and
take the subject out good
so always remember elbows pointed back
on your narrow push out again if you
progress in hop push and in good this is
one of my favorite workout it's a
love-hate relationship good narrow and
up good and then for the active rest we
want to be throwing some strips punches
keep going three more last one and now
get back out and throw me from straight
punches so left and right remember to
give me strong punches and I want you to
twist your torso at the same time okay
so not like this but really strong and
gives you total and twist at the same
time you will also be working on your
love handles
okay ladies straight punches look
straight ahead and really throw me those
punches
good keep going don't stop now you
should feel your arms and show this
working three
twist twist good so this workout really
works on arms and also at the twist it
works on your midsection three more
seconds and we want to get back down
onto the floor for spider-man pre-shop
click down onto the floor get into a
plank position for spider-man 3 shop
bring your elbow to your knee and your
elbow to your knee
good the alternate good lower body and
alternate good keep going again if this
is difficult get until knee elbow to
knee elbow to knee alright so that is
always a beginner option for every
workout because I believe that we all
need a stopping point okay so as you
progress and get up into a full vitamin
push-up good oh I can see my arms my
shoulders working and I track them now
get back cap into poop so again left and
right elbows on your face hook three
tweets three good remember the power
should be coming from a hip helping with
the upper body
good hook hook imagine you're punching
someone right at the cheek get cook and
cook so the other arm should always stay
up guarding your face because you do not
want to get punched
okay get hook tweet tweet the photo with
your legs and keep cooking left to right
guarding your face constantly and
looking at a target good keep going
three more seconds and it's back down to
tricep dip serve lift your butt up
alright really small movement bend your
elbows push up using your triceps
muscles hear it push up slow down and up
okay remember that the strength and the
power should be coming from your triceps
really small movement up and down up
good if you find this easy what you can
do is to elevate your legs onto a
stepper okay keep go
small movements up lick your butt up
down and push up with the triceps not
with your legs okay keep going
five more seconds and we want to get
back up into cross punches there back up
now cross and punch up so we did three
approaches whoo
and now it's all about elongating the
arm muscles and engaging the shoulder
muscles even more again with all punting
and kickboxing movement it's always
engaging the entire body so look up
twist and rotate your torso good the
rest arm should be always by your face
good kid going ladies to it and look the
opposite side ten more seconds and the
final arm workout will be playing up
down stay strong stay strong and now
let's get back down get into a plank
position and we want to come up all
right
and that's down and change all and right
down left up left down good and right up
and right down okay
remember minimal movement from your body
so it's really about your shoulder
muscles are muscles working and your
torso and of course keeping you strong
and solid nice what remember to breathe
in take the breathing and that's now up
few more and you will get one final
active rest slap one and a really simple
gentle active rest on circles so umpire
side just circle your arms and keep
rotating okay your arms should start to
be really sore right now and even this
more rotation will really work in a
triceps and it showed it so small but
quick rotation okay go good let's keep
doing it small and quick rotation and
now let's reverse
another side keep it up keep it strong
zone programs now keep it strong kids
which is out fire side and we will get a
one minute break right after this keep
going faster faster
very very good so now take a one-minute
break
drink some water kids are hydrated what
if to add and one more step
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so ii said you know all the workouts
give me a best effort and i want you to
really engage your entire body when it
comes to the active rest okay so let's
get back down onto the mat and let's
start with wide to narrow foo shaft
choose your option right let's go ready
and your wife is hop in narrow out push
your body and get your on and get back
out good very good
remember it gave gently at the map yes
up and in small movement out and hop in
out and in give it your best effort okay
if it struggles Midway then of course
take a step out push up get a step in
and back down okay good keep going and
it's straight into the keep boxing one
last one and now let's get up into
straight punches good straight punches
rotate strong punches look straight
ahead and punch good retail torso twist
twist so it's jab and a punch just and a
punch good okay we like I showed it
remember the power should be coming from
it also rotating keep it on top do not
give me this kind of punches all right I
don't want this I want to drop straight
punches right at the face level to show
the level to get keep punching five more
seconds and it's spider-man who shot
what
and now back down onto the mat let's go
into a plank position choose your option
by the man push up elbow to knee elbow
to knee good control we won't rush the
workout nice and control every single
move good
you should also feel your obliques
working our shoulder and also oblique
which will help with your left handle
good keep going fifteen more seconds
stay strong stay with me okay if I don't
stop you don't stop go low and push back
up
go low and push back up and up my
favorite quick hooks good left the right
left and right the last week right cheek
guard your face imagine that you're
looking somewhat straining to the eyes
and giving them strong nice hook okay
it's keep it strong this will really
burn on your triceps and work on the
triceps this is your cardio active rest
keep going twist your total twist your
legs good fifteen more seconds woo keep
going ladies
stay strong five more seconds and it's
on to tricep dip all right and I got a
small table with me if you want to
challenge yourself you can use a chair
or a table bring your body weight
forward okay and bring your body down
dip down and push yourself back up good
so your body should always stay close to
the chair all to the table like strict
if you find this challenging what you
can do it's been your knees and bring
your feet closer to your body so this is
an easier option okay so down as far as
I can keep your elbows pointed back and
push yourself back up
so challenge yourself bring your legs
further forward and push up
whoops my triceps are absolutely burning
five more seconds down and
up down and up give me one more down and
up oh my gosh I dressed let's not talk
enough so straight cross princess oh my
god
whoa all the upper body workout and
right after this you will not be able to
miss anything
keep going again look at the opposite
direction and twist and punch the
opposite direction you should feel your
heart rate elevated slightly remember
this is also the time for you to catch
your breath keep listening and we have
one final workout which is playing
uptown okay keep going one more and now
let's get down onto the mat into a plank
position beginners again remember you
can start on your toes I mean on your
knees and bring yourself back up
alright down bring yourself back out
okay so this is an either option as you
progress get onto your toes and push
yourself back up remember to keep your
body straight in life as possible small
movements on your total down and slowly
up good down and back up and control the
move good all right
elbows in line with your shoulders the
other workout use the car to bring your
body up at the same time keep going
we're not done yet
one final workout which is just Center
arm circles okay I want you to give me
more but really quick arm circles last
30 seconds okay both for really quick
arm circles lift your arms up your
elbows your shoulders and the triceps
all right now reverse really fast more
on circles I will be flipping out
keep going ten more second keep going
come on let's not drop down okay
stay strong stay with me whoa oh my gosh
I want a good deep stretch right now
well done so just bring your arms across
the left arm across and just stretch it
up okay and the opposite side just
gently stretch it out good this is to
stress out your shoulders all right I
bring a heart rate down you're gently
spread your shoulders down and then
tricep bring your arms up and back push
back okay keep your body standing tall
and pull your elbow and just pull it
gently for your triceps being stretched
out all right good
do not do this body straight up and now
change sides
opposite hand and just stretch it out
very good
all right and now just give your arms a
nice good shake well done I don't input
the with my arms right now so remember
the most effective way is to combine
strength training and also cardio
exercises one of my favorite workouts is
always to incorporate kickboxing to
really work on the upper body so you can
check out my kickboxing workout right
here and also more workout videos in the
description box below so do like this
video share with your friends and
subscribe to my youtube channel for a
lot more new and exciting content every
week all the best